the Netherlands allows it a prestine to
die Miley Cyrus weighs in on abortion
and Joe Biden runs in to plagiarism
trouble again this is the Ben Shapiro
show all righty a lot to get to today we
will jump into all of it but first you
remember when the left called the green
New Deal bold how about the bold
defensive anti-semitism in the house so
much boldness I think they're sort of
mistaking the word bold for something
else because the way I define bold is
the taste of freedom I get every morning
with my black rifle coffee I love black
rifle coffee I get up every morning
after a hard night of dealing with my
children and I need coffee to get
through this show black rifle coffee
makes it happen for me
black rifle coffee gives a portion of
their sales to veterans and first
responder causes black rifle coffee is
roasted or Durr guaranteeing a fresh
delicious coffee with every order black
rifles coffee club that make things easy
just pick your blend the amount you want
black rifle ships your coffee direct
your door every month hassle-free
for a bold cup of America's best coffee
visit black rifle coffee dot-com slash
Ben get 20% off your first purchase that
is black rifle coffee calm slash Ben for
20% off that first purchase black rifle
coffee calm slash but I know the guys
behind the company they are awesome
dudes and you will be helping them out
and also getting amazing coffee in the
process plus a percentage of their sales
goes to veterans and first responders so
what is there to lose except the
opportunity to get crappier coffee get
better coffee with black rifle coffee
calm slash Ben that is black rifle
coffee calm slash pen go check it out
right now
alrighty so the big story of the day is
this awful story from from the
Netherlands according to the Washington
Post a Dutch teenager who suffered from
depression post-traumatic stress
disorder and anorexia after being raped
as a child was allowed to die at her
home her sister confirmed on Sunday skin
was 17 years old in what she termed a
sad last post on Instagram Noah pot
joven 17 wrote saturday she would be
dead within 10 days but it had been so
long she added since she had really been
alive after years of struggling and
fighting it's over she wrote the
teenager from the city of Arnhem in the
eastern part of the Netherlands said she
had stopped eating and drinking and
would soon be released because my
suffering is unbearable her decision was
not impulsive she emphasized rather it
was the results of many conversations
and assessments offering her own blunt
review of her condition she observed
quote I survive and not even that
I breathe but no longer live it was
unclear whether her death had come with
the involvement of doctors whose
assistance she had at one point
requested she had asked the the doctors
in Netherland aboard in the Netherlands
if they would help her kill herself
a spokeswoman for a member of Dutch
parliament who had recently visited her
told Dutch news that she understood the
death to be a result of the girl's
refusal to eat the Vatican mourned her
passing Wednesday morning on Twitter
they said Noah's death is great loss for
any civil society and for Humanity we
must always assert the positive reasons
for life
Pope Francis issued a separate message
he said euthanasia and assisted suicide
are a defeat for all we are called never
to abandon those sort of suffering never
giving up but caring and loving to
restore hope assisted suicide is of
course legal in parts of the United
States as well as Europe it depends on
where you are what the rules are active
euthanasia is lawful only in places like
Belgium Luxembourg and the Netherlands
the Netherlands legalized the practice
of euthanasia in 2001 that was the year
that Noah was born the vote in Dutch
Parliament was the culmination of a
campaign according to the post that
began in 1973 following the prosecution
of a general practitioner who had ended
the life of her mother after a cerebral
hemorrhage left her partly paralyzed
deaf and mostly unable to speak the
end-of-life clinic in the hague where
Noah had sought services spells out
narrow circumstances under which doctors
may provide assisted dying requiring
that the patient makes a clear and
autonomous request and is enduring
unbearable and unendurable suffering
there must be no other reasonable
solution patients have to demonstrate
understanding of the consequences of
what they are requesting doctors are
required to seek counsel from an
independent colleague who is not
familiar with the patient children as
young as 12 can seek euthanasia under
Dutch law but those from 12 to 16 must
obtain parental consent so in the United
States you have to ask a parent for some
form of for some form of permission to
obtain an aspirin but apparently
children as young as 12 can seek
euthanasia under Dutch law and once
you're past 16 you don't need permission
from a parent's who seek physician
assisted suicide the procedure accounts
for 4.4 percent of all the deaths in the
Netherlands in 2017 of the 6600 cases
that were requests that were granted
most were in cases of untreatable cancer
a few involved psychiatric distress so
the controversy that's broken out here
is whether this girl actually received
euthanasia from the government or
whether she simply stopped eating and
the government refused to intubate her
refused to force-feed her effectively
NOAA initially approached the clinic
last year without her parents knowledge
she was turned away she was told she was
too young to die
she said they think I'm too young to die
she said I can't wait that long
because she was instructed to complete a
trauma treatment and wait until her
brain was more fully developed a
spokeswoman for the clinic did not
return a request for comment so it is
simply unclear at this point what
exactly the government's involvement was
NOAA had written a book in that book she
traced the origin of her mental anguish
at the age of eleven she was assaulted
at a school party and again at a
gathering of teenagers a year later when
she was 14 she writes she was raped by
two men in the elder veld neighborhood
of Arnhem for years she kept the
violation secret out of shame it was
only years later her family learned what
she had endured after her mother came
across a cachet of a cache of letters
saying goodbye to her loved ones
she remained too afraid to make a formal
declaration to the police Lisa vest
reveled the Dutch lawmaker who visited
Noah before her death when she was
surrounded by family and friends in her
living room said she was struck by the
teenagers strength she told their girl
and her that it was nice to see her
again although the circumstances were
surreal a spokesman for Westerville told
The Washington Post she didn't know more
about the circumstances of the
teenager's death the ministry of health
welfare and sport did not return a
request for comment suffice it to say
you do have to ask in this particular
case why so many people who believe that
subjective perception of the value of
human life is paramount why those people
would be upset about this this I
understand why I'm upset about this
because I believe that that human beings
have inherent value that human life has
inherent value and that inherent value
is not subject to the subjective
perceptions of either outsiders or the
ascent of the person whose human life we
are talking about in other words if you
decide to commit suicide you have
committed a sin against herself you have
committed an immoral act against
yourself and if you decide to commit
suicide in circumstances where a turn of
terminal cancer that is particularly
true now I've always said that when it
comes to euthanasia
I'm personally torn when you're talking
about somebody who has terminal cancer
who's days away from death the truth is
that we have palliative care now
palliative
is something the doctors engage in on a
regular basis across the United States
and Europe basically somebody's in the
hospital they're going to die instead of
putting them on some sort of life-saving
assistance you basically allow the
process to move forward and you palliate
the pain so for example you give them
morphine or something that's different
from taking active steps to kill
somebody that would be euthanasia I
think that euthanasia is wrong but at
least I see the argument in cases of
terminal care when you are talking about
a 17 year old girl who suffers from
psychological trauma you're talking
about an act of grave evil from my
perspective because what you are doing
is taking away the value of the human
life and if the government was complicit
in any way with this then this is
Orwellian horror that the government was
involved in and frankly even if the
government allowed this girl to starve
herself that is an Orwellian horror
because the fact is that government was
instituted to protect life liberty and
property and life is not subject to your
perception of the value of life life is
of objective merit but here's the
question if you believe that life is of
subjective value what's your problem
here and why is this sad the girl got
what she wanted right I mean well it's
it's sad I suppose that she not I
suppose it is sad obviously that she
suffered from something so terrible but
if you are on the left and you believe
that she she got to decide the value of
her own life this girl then why exactly
aren't you celebrating today the fact
that you made this decision
why aren't you celebrating the fact that
the state facilitated the decision
apparently why are you upset today I
understanding being upset about the fact
that this girl suffered I understand you
being upset about the fact that this
girl was mistreated and raped and all
the rest obviously but is there anything
inherently wrong with the
decision-making on the part of the state
I mean this is serious moral question
because it does go to an even more
serious moral question which is should
we evaluate life on an objective level
or should we evaluate life and science
should should really objective fact on
subjective merits meaning are things
only important because we think them so
or are they important in and of
themselves this debate extends all the
way to abortion I've discussed abortion
over the course of many years
what I've always said is that if you
believe there's an inherent value to
human life then you have to take
seriously the contention that human life
begins at conception and therefore that
there is something of value of objective
human value that must be protected
people on the Left have responded that
basically a human life is when a woman
decides a human life is and not even her
own life the baby's life is what the
woman like is what the woman suggested
as her subjective perception of the
value of what is growing inside of her
is more important than any objective
assessment of what it is that is growing
inside her and this is what leads the
Democratic Party to the bizarre
circumstance where they are claiming
that aborting up till the point of birth
is perfectly acceptable because after
all a woman may decide that that's not a
baby it's just a cluster of cells until
it's not a cluster of cells anymore at
least there's a consistent logic to that
but when people on the right suggest
that people on the far left are engaged
in a culture of death this is what
they're talking about what they're
talking about is once you devalue human
life to the subjective perception of its
value once human life becomes about not
whether it has inherent objective value
apart from anybody's subjective
perception of that fact once you start
talking about that it is incredibly easy
to dehumanize other groups of people it
is incredibly easy to take human life
with no more seriousness than a grain of
salt it is easy to end up in a
circumstance where a 17 year old girl
who suffers from depression and PTSD and
anorexia is allowed to starve to death
by the state or maybe be euthanized
depending on which account you believe
at this point and you ends up with these
these perverse moral absurdities like
the state of New York so the state of
New York has now decided that it is very
very important that declawing be banned
now I don't own a cat so I don't know
anything about declawing
it sounds like it's a pretty terrible
practice New York is now banning the
practice because it will now apparently
impose a $1,000 fine on veterinarians
who perform a procedure for non-medical
purposes because apparently declawing a
cat involves damaging the cat's toes one
of the several lawmakers to champion the
measure Assemblywoman Linda Rosenthal
Democrat of Manhattan was visibly
jubilant after the vote she had
previously rallied against declawing and
condemned its invasive nature and a
certain in a statement quote it's not
like getting a mani-pedi she said it's a
brutal surgical procedure so let's just
to get this straight the state of New
York is now going to find
veterinarians who perform declawing
$1,000 for every time they do this if
they perform the procedure for
non-medical purposes the state of New
York just lit up its state property pink
in honor of a bill that says you can
kill a fully formed human baby in the
womb up to the points it enters the
birth canal I mean you want to end up
with a perverse moral system that you
values human life this would be it right
here
listen I'm perfectly fine with banning
declawing frankly I don't have much of a
dog in the fight no pun intended but it
seems bad so I'm fine with the idea that
you shouldn't be able to make animals
suffer simply because you don't want
your furniture scratched but I also hold
that human life has a value if you're
more concerned about the toes of cats
than you are about the lives of babies
in the womb I would suggest that your
your devaluing of human life is perverse
deeply perverse and listen to the
language used by that assembly woman
it's a brutal surgical procedure on the
cat you know it's more brutal than
hurting a cat's toes crushing a baby's
skull and then sucking its brains into a
sink and then disposing of its body
parts see that that that seems a little
more brutal male if I just had to put
that like on a map of brutality it seems
like that's a little more brutal but
maybe that's just me I'm gonna get two
more of this the left culture of
devaluing human life if not a culture of
death in one second first losing your
hair sucks
two out of three dudes are going to
experience hair loss by the time they
are 35 and this is why you need keeps
it's the easiest and most affordable way
to keep the hair that you have these
fda-approved products used to cost a ton
of money but now thanks to keeps they're
finally inexpensive and they are easy to
obtain for five minutes now starting in
just 10 bucks per month you'll never
have to worry about hair loss again
which is a great relief you know male
pattern baldness runs in my family so it
keeps us fantastic getting started is
super easy signing up takes less than
five minutes just answer a few simple
questions snap some photos to complete
your online doctor consultation a
licensed physician will review your
information online recommend the right
treatment for you and then it shipped
right to your door every three months
keeps offers generic versions are the
only two FDA approved hair loss products
out there you may have tried them before
never for this price only ten bucks to
35 bucks a month plus now you can get
your first month for free that's a hell
of a deal forgetting to keep your hair
if you suffer from hair loss the last
thing you need is to wait to see a
doctor with keeps there's finally a way
to get the help you need when you need
it I mean really these things cost a
fortune
unless you get them with
and if you like I have male pattern
baldness running in your family this is
really a fantastic choice goto keeps
calm slash Ben and receive your first
month of treatment for free for a
limited time receive that first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash Ben so back to this New York law
so New York just celebrated the killing
of the unborn by lighting up its
buildings pink but they are definitely
standing strong when it comes to onic
ectomy which is decline New York
director for Humane Society of the
United States Brian Shapiro no relation
who advocated the legislation explained
the procedure is not as simple as
removing a cat's nail it requires mp's
hitting the last bone segment and a
cat's toes he caught he said that the
legislation was a great victory the
origins of decline date back to 1952 the
Washington Post is really ecstatic about
all of this I don't believe there will
be any editorials about whether the
value of cat life is more important than
the value of saving your furniture
I don't believe there'll be any opposing
editorials on that there will be however
an opposing editorial every single day
in the Washington Post about the value
of protecting the unborn there they will
they will go all out so if you seek to
protect the unborn it's because you're a
vicious brutal sexist if you seek to
protect cats that's because you're a
humane human being this has to do with
the general culture that suggests that
human life is only as valuable as your
perception of human life and that's how
you end up with these bizarre logic that
is used by so many members of the left
so let's take an example it will be
goldberg on the view she articulates a
message that so many people on the mess
on the left are constantly articulating
that message is that when it comes to
abortion people on the right simply want
to be involved with women's bodies this
is a very stupid argument it's always
been a very stupid argument I am NOT
interested in the bodies of anybody
except for my wife because my wife
happens to be incredibly hot I'm really
not interested in certainly Whoopi
Goldberg's coochie as she puts it but
Whoopi Goldberg suggests that nikki
Haley is deeply interested in Whoopi
Goldberg's coochie which would be a
revelation for sure that certainly be on
the cover of In Touch magazine where
that the truth it turns out that nikki
Haley is pro-life but Whoopi Goldberg
has demeaned human life to the point
that human life doesn't exist so long as
it is in
side her because she has a subjective
perception that it ought not to exist so
here is Whoopi Goldberg making that
ridiculous case much more than an
abortion clinic much much more they do
many more things so basically you're
saying I'm getting rid of this so you
can't have this conversation anymore
because I'll tell you the truth if a
woman wants to do this she's going to do
it
taking choice only means you making it
more dangerous now
no again I don't say that everybody has
to believe but I say you want you want
to have choice I don't want you with my
kuchi I don't want you in my kit and it
no one's interested will be sorry to
break it to you but that's that's not
something anybody is thinking about
frankly what everybody is thinking about
is the value of the human life in the
womb but if you believe that human life
can be boiled down to subjective notions
of value then of course this is where
you end up because your view is as
valuable as my view may be your view is
more valuable than my view and that
means that if you decide to stamp out
the life while I'm no problem no problem
once you turn subjective values of human
life into the norm you shouldn't be
surprised when people are dehumanized
and this is how you have ended up at the
point where the left doesn't just say
safe legal and rare anymore the left
doesn't say abortion a difficult
decision taking into account all sorts
of terrible factors there's a vast gap
between how op-ed pages handle the
abortion issue and how the hardcore left
on social media and many of the of the
advocates in the media handle the
abortion issue what I mean is that the
op-ed pages typically I replete with
terrible horror stories from the fringes
of occurrence so what they will do is
they will find some case where a woman
has a taste ax baby and she's told she
has at a sex baby in month two and then
she carries it all the way to term and
she suffers for two years with the
tay-sachs baby who suffers greatly and
then dies now say this is why abortion
ought to be legal okay that isn't an
emotionally driven argument that at
least there is an appeal to but the
basic argument there is that only in
extraordinary circumstances should
abortion really be on the table but the
left doesn't actually believe that the
left has moved on to it's time to fully
celebrate abortion abortion is worth
celebrating
of course abortion is worth celebrating
if your perspective is that human life
is of subjective value so you end up
with IDIA sees like Miley Cyrus uh how
this person is
famous is absolutely beyond me I know
our producer Nick has a strange fondness
for some of her songs when she plays on
the banjo it's very bizarre but in any
case Miley Cyrus tweeted out a photo of
herself licking a cake that says on an
abortionist health care first of all not
sanitary do not lick that cake that
other people might want a piece of that
cake so there's that number two why does
every picture of Miley Cyrus feature her
sticking her tongue on things it's very
bizarre I don't know what her fixation
is with putting her tongue on things but
I mean I have a feeling I understand
what the marketing aspect of that is but
she tweeted out very special collab with
Planned Parenthood for America happy
hippy and Marc Jacobs so fashion brands
are now getting involved which I think
suggest to pro-lifers perhaps you
shouldn't shop Marc Jacobs any time soon
I think that's fair there's to be
announced very soon 9y is their hashtag
women's rights are human rights hashtag
don't f with my freedom and then they're
a bunch of emojis of a dress and then a
and then a church with love signs and
then I guess a transgender symbol or
something
yeah and that that wasn't all Miley
Cyrus tweet again this is a celebration
it's party in the USA abortion it's not
just that abortion is is something that
is a serious moral considerations party
in the usa' time and it has to do with
women's vaginas
that's what Miley Cyrus is very
concerned about and she proved that by
tweeting out a bizarre video of herself
fingering various fruit in close-up it's
supposed to be obviously some sort of
reference to female genitalia so it's
got her like putting her fingers inside
cantaloupes and papayas again I don't
know why she's so intent unsanitary with
food like wear gloves I mean the lunch
lady wears gloves I don't understand why
you no one wants to eat that cantaloupe
anymore you've destroyed that papaya for
all time
I mean that that grapefruit is not
saying I would not serve that to anybody
that grapefruit so she's already ruined
a k-cup a pie a cantaloupe and a
grapefruit all in the name of abortion I
mean forget about subjective value of
human life there's an object of value to
clean cleanliness and food preparation
preparation and in any case it does show
you how you get from safe legal and rare
to let's celebrate it because once it's
subjective if you don't care about it
you don't care about it there's this
amazing threat on Twitter where somebody
had tweeted out a picture
a miscarried fetus and something like
ten weeks and miscarried fetuses at ten
weeks look like babies I know I have
seen them okay they they look like tiny
human beings it's it's awful and sad and
terrible and people on the left we're
tweeting back things like I would stomp
on that I would throw that away I would
burn that really that I'm not making
this up this was a full Twitter thread
the replies were just horrendous this is
what happens when human life becomes
devalued so here is my question for
folks on the left if human life is of
subjective value why are you sad today
do you think anything wrong happened in
the case of the seventeen-year-old girl
in the Netherlands who decided to commit
suicide and was not stopped from doing
it by the state now she could have been
given treatment a lot of these cases
some psychiatric treatment some
medication is useful suicidality in many
cases is treatable you know do you think
that anybody did anything wrong in this
case it was just a sad story because
something bad happened to this this
young woman and then it's sort of happy
because she got what she wanted in the
end I mean how do you feel about this if
on a gut level you hear that story then
you say to yourself the state did
something wrong this girl's life should
have been protected this girl should be
alive today she's 17 years old she's
physically healthy there's nothing wrong
with her physically
she just had been a victim of rape and
PTSD by the way the same people in the
Netherlands who are happy to facilitate
her death are I'm sure happy to let the
rapist out in four years or less if you
think there's something wrong with that
I would ask you why you think that maybe
it's because you actually do indeed
believe that there is an objective value
to human life that her own subjective
assessment of the value of her own life
was not correct and when people are
suicidal and they believe their life is
not worth living that their assessment
can be wrong that their subjective
perception of reality is not in fact
reality and if that's the case maybe you
need to reconsider how you feel about
the value of human life and that human
life exists in the womb and against
whose subjectivity in science a little
bit more in just one second first this
Father's Day give dad a gift he packed
with the Omaha Steaks he craves okay let
me let me just tell you something
Omaha Steaks I have lots of friends who
eat Omaha Steaks they are unbelievable
according to many of the people in this
very office go to Omaha Steaks comm
enter coach
hero in the search bar for 74 percent
off the Father's Day steak fix gift
package a $235 value right now for only
$59.99 so if you order it now here's
what you're going to get like this is an
incredible deal and just on a pure
buying meet basis this is an incredible
deal you order now here's what you get
to filet mignons to top sirloins two
pork chops two for Omaha steak burgers
for gourmet jumbo Franks four
chicken-fried steaks all beef meatballs
four chicken breasts for caramel apple
tartlets a packet of Omaha Steaks and
signature seasoning and you get 4 extra
Omaha steak burgers for free you're
gonna get all of that at 74 percent off
that is that hell of a gift for dad or
stock up for your incredible summer
grilling the summer is coming again
order right now you can get this
exclusive Omaha Steaks Father's Day
steak fix package valued at 235 bucks
for just $59.99 I mean you're not gonna
get more meat and better meat than that
at any price just go to Omaha Steaks com
type coach Shapiro into the search bar
don't wait the offer ends soon go to
Omaha Steaks com type chip hero in the
search bar to get the Father's Day steak
fix package today I mean if you know
your dad's gonna love it your dad's
gonna love it it it sounds amazing
Omaha Steaks com type Shapiro in that
search bar and get the special deal okay
so speaking of the perversion of science
on behalf of the subjective Jessie
single who's a very good writer on
science he is not of the political right
but he happens to be rooted in reality
when he talks about things he has a
piece in his newsletter today about a
New York Times article so this New York
Times article was published about a week
ago and it talked about chest binding it
talked about how chest binding may
actually have risks it turns out that if
you are a young woman who wishes to look
like a man and so you bind your chest
back this may in fact damage your
breasts who would have thought
just like foot-binding will damage your
feet it turns out that if you bind a
physical part of yourself down this may
damage you in some way so this article
by Amy Sohn says it used to be that when
a 13-year old one in a binder for school
events a trip to Staples for today's
tweens and teens who identify as gender
non-conforming or transgender shopping
for a binder may mean a compression
undergarment worn to flatten breasts
made of thick spandex and nylon
binders resembled tight undershirts
creating a masculine profile yet
me the American Academy of Pediatrics
has estimated that 0.7% of 13 to 17 year
olds in the United States about a
hundred fifty thousand identify as
transgender now the truth is a huge
number of these people will de
transition as soon as they grow out of
their adolescence the number of young
people who identify as transgender or
gender fluid or gender non-binary it
decreases radically over time dr. John
stever assistant professor of pediatrics
at Mount Sinai Adolescent Health Center
in Manhattan and has evaluated over 500
patients from ages 8 to 23 said that
almost 95% of the trans-masculine
teenagers in the program bind binders
are not classified as medical devices
some doctors and parents have concerns
about their safety common-sense binding
guidelines include don't use ace
bandages or duct tape don't bind at
night limit a binder to eight to ten
hours a day don't shower in it don't
wear too and don't wear one that is too
small so they're pushing these products
that are specifically designed to press
breasts into the into the chest cavity
effectively speaking and it turns out
this may have some damage from people it
turns out that this may hurt people dr.
steve ur says most of his patients who
use blind binders then tell me the next
things they want to do like testosterone
mastectomy and maybe phalloplasty
ninety-five percent of the people I've
evaluated get started on cross hormones
and then the article talks about the
possibility of damage you know that this
can actually hurt people well obviously
it can hurt people dr. Alana sharer a
pediatrician founder of the Child and
Adolescent gender Center at the
University of California San Francisco
email that binders can be physically
very uncomfortable and can cause
problems especially if overused or
ill-fitting so it's important that every
youth weigh the risks and benefits for
themselves and have access to quality
well fitted binders even those are
correlated with negative health effects
as the article though there have been no
studies on binding and Adolescent Health
because of ethical concerns about
research on minors I love that I love
that so there have been no studies on
binding and Adolescent Health because we
are deeply worried about the ethical
concerns of research on minors instead
we just have no research on it and then
the kids walk around and we pretend like
it's not damaging them because of a 2017
study by students at Johns Hopkins
Bloomberg School of Public Medicine
looked at 1,800 trans-masculine adults
with a median age of 23 78% of
respondents said they had bound
a year over 1/2 pound in average of
seven days a week 66% were interested in
top surgery which is the physical
removal of the breasts an additional
13.1% had already had the surgery
participants reported a statistically
significant improvement in mood after
binding which makes sense if you are if
you are gender dysphoria then presumably
if you now resemble a member of the sex
that you wish to belong to then this may
alleviate some of your mood but here's
the problem as for physical effects
97.2% of the group that bound reported
at least one negative physical symptoms
such as back pain overheating chest pain
shortness of breath
other symptoms included numbness bad
posture and lightheadedness it is also
unclear what exactly the long-term
effects of binding your breasts are
binding is not benign says one woman
says it encourages the idea that
people's distress in anger and trauma
should be turned inward toward their own
bodies instead of outward toward the
culture that feels oppressive to them
that's breach on true the spokeswoman
for fourth wave now which was founded by
a woman whose daughter told her that she
was trans at 11 and then she realized
that she was not trans after a while
okay so this article is a fairly
objective take on chest binding meaning
it may alleviate psychological pain for
some people for a while also there could
be serious physical side effects -
shocker binding your breasts down as
Jessy single rights this has prompted
folks on the left to go nuts BuzzFeed's
LGBTQ editor BuzzFeed is just what a
garbage publication BuzzFeed often is
BuzzFeed's LGBTQ editor Shannon Keating
tweeted today and today's anti-trans
scaremongering from the end from the New
York Times an entire story for him to
highlight the physical downsides of
chest binding no mention of trans youth
suicide rates no quote from gender
non-conforming people for whom binding
is life-saving and who gets quoted
though anti-trans hate group fourth wave
now now that of course is not an
accurate summation of the piece I just
read you a large part of the piece but
the the particular take here which is
that it is bad to report on objective
facts like binding your breasts may have
physical effects that this is considered
offensive by people on a subjective
perception of reality is more important
than an objective assessment of reality
that's
dangerous stuff one subjectivity becomes
the order of the day you can kiss
goodbye to science you can kiss goodbye
to a republic because you can't have
conversations with people anymore their
subjective perception of reality is more
important than reality this is why it is
a Bugaboo of mine when people say things
like it's my truth it's my truth there's
no such thing as your truth there is the
truth and there is your opinion and your
opinion may resemble the truth or it may
be drawing upon facts that are the truth
but it is still your opinion and the
fact and for a lot of folks on the Left
they want to boil down issues of
objective value whether we are talking
about human life or whether we are
talking about science whether we're
talking about biological sex whether we
are talking about objective metrics of
academic performance if you want to boil
all that down to how you feel about
those things you can't have a
conversation anymore because if I
question your feelings I am then
questioning your identity and if I
question your identity then we can't
have a conversation it used to be that
we were able to separate facts from
opinion or at least we tried to do this
now we have determined that we can no
longer do this and the media have been
so complicit in this move so incredibly
complicit in this move data are held to
be secondary to the narrative because
the narrative is a subjective take on
facts the narrative is a story that you
tell about the facts but it is not the
fact it is the way the human mind draws
a story from a set of facts and we can
argue about whether that story is
properly drawn from the data points
provided but you can't argue the data
points unless the data points themselves
are wrong instead we have decided that
if the data points contradict a
narrative the data points go out the
window this is how you end up with
stupidities like the media pushing false
narratives about a set of facts in
police brutality cases for example there
are some police brutality cases where
the set of facts supports police
brutality there are some police
brutality cases in which the facts do
not support that but according to the
media no every time the police are
brutal this supports a widespread
narrative that the police are always
brutal every time there is a racist in
the United States this supports the idea
that the entire United States is
systemically racist you drawing your
narrative from an anecdotal piece of
evidence not based on generalizable data
or ignoring generalizable data in favor
of a particular narrative is an act of
intellectual bad faith and we are moving
toward that those those acts on a
routine basis and makes it impossible to
have a conversation
really it does because the minute you
side of fact everybody begins to get
uptight you're contradicting who I
overriding my truth are you denigrating
my experiences no you can have your
experiences and maybe your experiences
are the truth or maybe they're your
subjective perception of what happened
okay in a minute we're gonna get to the
20/20 rays first there's a widely held
belief the procrastination is a bad
thing I'm one of the people who tends to
believe procrastination is a bad thing
but not always sometimes life is not
quite so black-and-white sometimes
procrastination can work in your favor
for example if you need life insurance
but you've been putting it off
congratulations to you you have managed
to procrastinate long enough for
technology to make it easy policy genius
is the easy way to shop for insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need a
life insurance but you've been busy
doing literally anything else go check
out policy genius right now it's the
easy way to compare all the top insurers
and find the best value for you policy
genius com nobody wants to shop for life
insurance which is why they made it so
easy they want to ensure that you do the
responsible thing and it is by the way
the responsible thing to ensure that
your family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you go
check them out right now at policy
genius combien adult policy genius.com
okay coming up we're gonna get to
another bizarre narrative a subjective
perception of reality that is not in
fact the truth but backs a particular
political point of view I'll get to that
in just a second first you have to head
over to daily wire calm when you do get
the rest of this show live yeah man you
know that means two additional hours a
day of content and we are bringing you
great content yesterday for example we
had kenneth starr on to discuss the
Muller investigation and all of its
ramifications
we have senators we have governors we
have newsmakers they've all sorts of
people on the show we also have two
additional hours of commentary which
means that whatever happens during the
day you're gonna get my take on it and
the latest updates on the news all you
have to do is go subscribe also you get
Matt Walsh's show and andrew Clavin the
show and if you want Michael Knowles's
show which again I don't know why you'd
want that but if you want it I suppose
you can have it if you go get the daily
water subscription right now for $9.99 a
month also you get this the very
greatest
and beverage vessels look at this thing
this left is that's it this leftist
years how to encode tumblr I mean it is
magnificent
and for 99 dollars a year that annual
subscription you can get that you can
also get access to our Sunday special on
Saturdays our D Day episode last week I
thought was just terrific
we interviewed for survivors of World
War two people with soldiers who fought
on d-day I thought it was a great
episode and in honor of d-day which is
tomorrow I think that you should go
check that out too lots of good stuff
happening over at daily where I can also
subscribe at YouTube and iTunes you know
please leave a sort of view we
definitely appreciate that
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so speaking of drawing
narratives from a set of facts that
simply do not back the narrative bill de
blasio groundhog killer
theythey Stalin of groundhogs bill de
blasio did a press conference yesterday
when he talked about anti-semitism why
was he talking about anti-semitism well
because in his city the city of what she
is mayor hate crimes against Jews have
spiked dramatically anti-semitic
incidents have spiked by ninety percent
in his city not a single one of those
anti-semitic incidents has been linked
to white supremacists this cuts against
the argument by the left that all
anti-semitism is effectively white
supremacists anti-semitism now me
pointing this out is not me downplaying
white supremacist anti-semitism those
people are evil they are supremely evil
they have threatened my life they've
threatened my family's life they have
made my life miserable there's a reason
I have 24/7 security and it is mostly
for white supremacists anti-semites
they've shot up several synagogues in
the past year or so they shot up the
Chabad of Poway they shot up the
pittsburgh synagogue so white
supremacists are evil none of this is to
downplay their evil but the people who
are abusing Jews in New York City are
not white supremacist the people who are
abusing Jews in New York City are
largely doing so in Williamsburg and
many of them are members of racial
minority groups that is just the
statistical fact Bill DeBlasio comes out
however and he says because he's got a
narrative that has no relation to fact
but he has a subjective perception of
reality that he is going to impose on
reality from above he said on Tuesday
that anti-semitism is a right-wing
movement only right-wing there is no
left-wing anti-semitism poof it's gone
amazing he says I think the ideological
movement that his anti-semitic is the
right-wing movement is what Bill de
Blasio said even well he continues to
kowtow to the folks like el Han Omar and
receipted Talib inside his own party
even as Jeremy Corbyn in Britain who is
an open anti-semite who can sorts with
terrorists even while Jeremy Corbyn
leads the Labour Party don't worry
there's no such thing as left-wing
anti-semitism and hatred of Israel and a
belief that Israel should disappear
that's not anti-semitism at all DeBlasio
said he did not agree with a claim by a
reporter that there is also rising
anti-semitism on the left in the BDS
movement and around the world really I
mean that this is de Blasio is an idiot
but I mean this kind of statement is so
obtuse and the reverse of rial
it's almost impossible to overstate he
says there is no rising anti-semitism on
the left in the BDS movement and to and
around the world has he visited a
college campus has he seen people like
Mark Lamont Hill saying from the river
to the sea Palestine and shall be free
has he not seen the relationship between
the BDS movement and the terror masters
who originally created it
de Blasio said quote I want to be very
very clear the violent threat the threat
that is ideological is very much from
the right I mean I would ask Jews in
Europe if that's the case address
choosing Williamsburg if that's the case
the Jews who are being attacked on the
streets in Williamsburg in his town
those people are not being attacked by
white supremacist in fact not a single
case can be traceable to a white
supremacist the New York Times admitted
this back in October I've talked about
this piece many times because I think
it's one of the most astonishing pieces
of journalism I have ever seen in a
major newspaper the New York Times ran a
piece back in October of last year
talking about the radical uptick in
anti-semitism in New York and they said
yeah we haven't covered it why haven't
we covered it because it doesn't easily
conform to an ideological narrative they
admit this openly the New York Times
said openly the reason we didn't cover
this is basically because it wasn't a
bunch of white supremacist from upstate
Idaho because it was a bunch of minority
folks who were beating on a bunch of
Jews in Williamsburg amazingly
de Blasio wasn't just talking about us
incidents if he wanted to say violent
incidents in the US are largely from
white supremacists at least you can make
that case but he was talking about
international incidents as well and
that's absolute crap the fact is that if
you look at the international incidents
if you look in Europe a huge number of
anti-semitic attacks have been
perpetrated by radical Muslims in Europe
and those radical Muslims have been
protected by left-wing governments and
by left-wing allies the remarks of
course drew immediate blowback from the
city council members on both side of the
political aisle so long as they were
Jewish that's the way this works if
you're a Jewish Democrat then you're
allowed to come out against Bill de
Blasio if you are a non Jewish Democrat
you have to pretend that he's not a
hi I'm joy to Brooklyn Democrat said I
don't agree with the mayor I haven't
seen any white supremacists coming in
here committing these hate crimes
indeed according to the New York Post
New York Police Department chief Dermot
Shaye said at the same press conference
that perpetrators of hate crimes run the
gamut from teens to people with mental
illness to first-time offenders in
career
for example a 16 year old recently
turned himself in for punching an
Orthodox Jewish man in the head in
Williamsburg
Staten Island Republican Borelli called
the mayor's position laughable he said a
simple look at where an sees medicate
crimes have occurred justice proves this
unless you count central Brooklyn as the
home of a vast right-wing conspiracy
Bill DeBlasio regularly says stupid
things but this is literally the
stupidest effing thing he's ever said
accurate fact check harsh but true again
when the data don't support your belief
system I suppose that you just run with
the narrative anyway your subjective
perception of reality is all that
matters this is why the left has worked
just endlessly to try and shift the
entire anti-semitism discussion from
anti-semitism to the general right wing
is responsible for anything this is how
you end up with BuzzFeed trying to
report that I'm responsible for
anti-semitic attacks hey that's how you
end up there you just ignore data and
instead you look to what makes you feel
better about yourself what massage is
your feelings all right coming up we're
gonna get to the 2020 race oh the 2020
race Joe Biden is finally running into a
little bit of trouble I mentioned
yesterday a poll from CNN that showed
that his support had dropped from 39% to
32% and the insane contention by Ryan's
strike who's a reporter over there that
this was a minor this was a minor
decline hey losing 7% from 39 to 32 and
bring yourself within shooting distance
of Bernie Sanders that is not a minor
decline well now Joe Biden is being hit
with accusations of plagiarism according
to the Washington Post Joe Biden's
presidential campaign lifted language
without credit at times word for word
when crafting it's education and climate
plans incidents the campaign
acknowledged and said were inadvertent
the incidents appears to be staff errors
when dealing but when detailing Biden's
policies they underscored how hastily
his campaign was attempting to put out
specific proposals but the issue is a
particularly sensitive one for Biden
whose 1988 campaign was derailed after
he plagiarized in speeches rhetoric used
by British politician Neil Kinnick
reports also emerge to use lines from
two Democrats Robert F Kennedy and
Hubert Humphrey without attribution
Biden had also been cited for plagiarism
in a paper during law school he quit the
campaign shortly after the flurry of
uses was reported Biden's campaign said
they would update his policy plans
laya Stokes a political scientist at UC
Santa Barbara
she said Biden appears to be taking
ideas from other people and not giving
them credit you can't do that
it speaks of pulling an all-nighter and
reading off of your friends essay I love
how everybody in the media and on the
Left is struggling not to use the word
plagiarism so the Washington Post
reporter refers back to Biden's
plagiarism from before but I promise you
that if Ted Cruz just lifted language
direct from Heritage Foundation for his
2016 website that would have been cited
as plagiarism and then of course they
points out other campaigns have used
unattributed language similar to that
crafted by primary sources a policy plan
by Senator Kamala Harris includes the
line that black women are three to four
times more likely to die from pregnancy
related causes than white women that is
identical to a reference in an American
Heart Association document its statistic
campaign spokesman Ian Simms said when
asked for comment and that at least I
think there's a fair contention to be
made if you lift a stat it's hard to
rewrite a stat dramatically but if you
do it Biden did and you lift the entire
policy language that's a problem in case
of his education policy Biden used a
sentence word-for-word from an education
policy publication from the group of XQ
Institute who after the Washington Post
contacted the campaign about the
sentence it had to link to the
Institute's publication now watch as the
media tried to defend him so Michael
Grunwald who is a reporter for Politico
he tweets out we're supposed to be mad
at Biden because he copied a few lines
of his climate plan from environmental
groups
that's not plagiarism that's agreeing no
that's that's plagiarism like I you
can't use that in any other circumstance
if I write a book and then I just lift
an entire paragraph without any citation
whatsoever that is not me just agreeing
with the source material that is
plagiarism plagiarism is you take
somebody else's work without crediting
them and then you attribute it to
yourself which is exactly what the
campaign did here and it's not just that
Joe Biden is running into headwinds
because he just he's not great at this
guy's I mean the reason that Joe Biden
and that I had said his best day would
be his first day is because eventually
people were gonna have to see Joe Biden
campaign and when Joe Biden campaigns it
ain't great for him here is Joe Biden
yesterday downplaying the threat of
China on the global stage we're in a
position where we have the most agile
venture capitalists in the world they
know I mean it's not like we're the
they're bad guys they that we were the
best at doing it our workers are
literally three times as productive as
workers in the Far East I mean sue me in
Asia and they're three times productive
and so what are we what are we worried
about yeah you say what are we worried
about in terms of China's economy well I
agree with him to the extent that
China's economy is not as powerful as
people say that it is but China is a
global threat and town playing that
global threat is not a particularly
smart move
the CNN panel yesterday basically
laughed at Biden because there was a
report from the New York Times the back
in 1987 Biden went around claiming that
he had marched for civil rights when he
never did here's the CNN panel actually
scoffing openly the Democratic
frontrunner when he gets very
comfortable out on the stump speaking
and other things he is tended to
embellish he has tended to you know make
things sound slightly rosier than they
are now his aides went back to say look
he was in office marching for the idea
of civil rights but was not actually
marching in the streets but that would
not fly but I'm saying that in today so
the you know the fact that you know the
fact that CNN is laughing and Joe Biden
is not a good plan for Joe Biden the
guns are starting to open up on him
Biden wisely is trying to ignore the
provocation yesterday he was asked a
bunch of questions about Democrats
criticizing him and he tried to simply
walk past it I'm not sure he can breath
past it for much longer
see you around
so it is it is you know Joe Biden can
only ignore this for so long and the
attacks on him are only going to grow
from here the real problem with the
plagiarism thing here is not the Joe
Biden is lifting language per se you
know that is a problem and Joe Biden has
a long history of it but it is another
indicator that Joe Biden is not
authentic that Joe Biden lifts his
sources from other places us his stories
from other people he lifted his entire
childhood basically from Neil Kinnock in
that 1988 campaign if he underscores
that again it's gonna be a problem for
him a gaffe is simply when people show
you the truth about themselves
unintentionally and that is what is
happening with Biden right now he is a
person with no new ideas he's a person
who grabs his ideas from other people
and then tries to pass them off as his
own he's never been a leader in any
serious way that you can speak of and
this is why all of the media enthusiasm
is moving over to people like Pete Budaj
edge or Elizabeth Warren or maybe comma
Harris anybody who can present something
new Joe Biden is a throwback now that is
his appeal is that he feels solid but
that solidity can be broken down by a
bunch of progressives in his own party
who decides to tear him down over being
inauthentic not sufficiently woke not
sufficiently leftist I think that the
the erosion of Joe Biden may have just
begun and maybe we may be watching it in
progress remember we're still a year out
from the primaries guys alrighty so time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
so my wife and I have been watching old
screwball comedies and these are just
they're wonderful they're just happy
movies they make you happy watching them
they are designed to be fun and humorous
there's a this movie is called bringing
up baby it's considered one of the great
screwball comedies of all time Howard
Hawks directed Katharine Hepburn and
Cary Grant Katharine Hepburn is
extraordinarily young this is a 1938
film so this is one of her first major
roles and Cary Grant's is of course
incredibly charming on screen here's a
little bit of the trailer for bringing
up baby
magnet I hope you realize that you've
made a perfect fool of yourself in front
of everyone and you finished yes there
are bugs with these old screwball
comedies that are really terrific I
think maybe over the next week or so
I'll start recommending some more of
these screwball comedies I read from out
of the middle of Arsenic and Old Lace
another Cary Grant film from the from
the 1940s that all of these things are
just there's nothing wrong with making
films that make people happy I know that
we're not allowed to do that anymore I
think that we're supposed to denigrate
films that make people happy so the real
reason people are going to see all the
Marvel Universe films is because they're
basically happy upbeat films and they're
basically they're not about social
justice woek messaging that's sort of
when the media loves it when they become
that but the reason the Marvel Universe
was successful is because the movies are
just fun to watch and it's ok to go to a
movie because it's fun to watch without
any broader message I'm gonna recommend
tomorrow another movie called Sullivan's
Travels I talked about this on the radio
show yesterday Sullivan's Travels is is
a film about a director who of comedies
and he decides that he wants to get woke
basically he wants to do some social
justice messaging he's not making
important films and this upsets him very
much and so he goes and he lives the
life of a basically and he
unintentionally ends up being treated as
a thrown in jail being on a chain
gang and all the rest and he ends up
with the chain gang watching a movie
which they're allowed to watch it once a
month and it ends up being one of his
comedies and all of the members of the
chain gang are laughing and he realizes
you know what comedy is kind of
important you know non offensive just
funny things it relieves tension it
makes it gives us a social space to
share you know the movies used to do
this for us increasingly they do not now
all the oscar-nominated movies do not
it's important to remember back in the
day a lot of these kinds of movies were
actually nominated for Best Picture
right the Philadelphia Story another
screwball comedy from 1940 that was
nominated for Best Picture as well so it
used to be the movies were fun I'd like
to see the movies get fun again although
I think that fun may have been outlawed
okay time for some things that I hate
okay so over in Britain protesters are
being attacked there's this new fangled
thing on the left where if somebody on
the right is hit with a milkshake then
that is just funny it's not in any way
dangerous or bad and people on the right
have said physical assault is still
physical assault you have to have some
rules against this and people on the
left like well our milkshake brings all
the boys to the yard people on the Left
are very into the idea that if you hit
somebody with a milkshake because
milkshakes are inherently funny then
that is not a problem at all as we see
the sort of milkshake stuff leads to
other things cuz there's an uh there was
an assault yesterday an anti Trump rally
in in Britain where an older fellow was
hit with a milkshake and he immediately
turn around and sock the guy who hit the
book shake which haze perfectly with it
is right to hit me with a milkshake I'll
sock it to ya things got really ugly
over in London yesterday
people need to calm down Trump is an
elected leader of democracy nonetheless
you know the ugliness that is being
pushed in our politics is really bad
stuff there's an older gentleman being
assaulted on the street
[Music]
very nice very nice guys you said it you
did a great job yeah the fact that if
you don't like titled Trump here now
like attacking random old servers on the
street is pretty pretty incredible
that's solid stuff okay other things
that I hate so Chris Cuomo the the less
smart of the Cuomo brothers which is a
hell of a recommendation he was very
upset yesterday when I was he upset well
because one of the ex deputies at
Parkland was arrested the ex deputy
whose name was Scott Peterson 56 was
terminated from his position and charged
with multiple counts of child neglect on
Tuesday because an internal
investigation found he retreated while
students were under attack in a February
2018 shooting the left 17 people dead
Peterson absolutely refused to do his
duty he was then now he's being
prosecuted for it Scott Israel has lost
his job he was the head of the Broward
County Sheriff's Department he was
terrible at his job here was Chris Cuomo
lamenting how it's like the United
States has fault more broadly that this
guy is going to jail not the fault of a
duly constituted law enforcement officer
who's being paid for his job and who not
only failed to charge into the fray who
then told other law enforcement
officials to say 500 yards away from a
shooter who is going around door to door
and killing students name is Scott
Peterson and he's now facing a lot of
criminal charges 11 counts felony child
neglect his actions or inaction during
the shooting we remember 17 are dead not
that he's why they are dead specifically
we know that only gets attributed to the
gunman but I guess what really gets me
is this is what we decide to act on
right this is this is the move that
makes the most sense after a shooting
this is the best we can do like I say
it's often misunderstood but it's true
only in America do you respond to
something like this Wow incredible
journalism there from from Chris Cuomo
and Don Lemon a repository of
intelligence on CNN I can't imagine why
the ratings are just awful Chris Cuomo
yeah it turns out that if you sign up as
a law enforcement officer and then you
run away from a fight where kids are
getting shot and you have a gun on your
hip
yeah you might get prosecuted and that's
a good thing that's a good thing that
numerical you get prosecuted this is how
you get law enforcement officers doing
their damage
job but apparently it's very bad CNN by
the way their coverage of parkland has
been garbage from beginning to end
it just shows how shameful it was when
they did that CNN Parkland Town Hall
which turned into 15 minutes hate from
1984 where everybody basically got
together and yelled at Dana lash and
Marco Rubio and suggested they were
responsible for the shooting and then
they won an award from USC Annenberg
Center for media for it the media did a
garbage shop on that so I love a media
that are now defending the deputy Scott
Peterson who abandoned children who are
being shot but declaring the Dana lash
and Marco Rubio were responsible for the
shooting just amazing amazing journalism
in guys okay we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content so be there or be
square I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
president Trump spends his waning hours
with the Queen mean tweeting a has-been
singer from the 70s Joe Biden does the
one thing he wasn't supposed to do and
Dutch politicians allow a 17 year old
girl to kill herself we will examine
washed-up psychos check it out on the
Michael Noel's show